[Music]
my father he cooked it over it and he
didn't I think he was alive was it like
Sofia George is 17 years old her sister
Gloria is 19 the hearing is damaged from
the explosion by this year I can hear
that all Sun and the blasting zone it
reminds me the incident on Easter Sunday
they left home with their father down
these streets to st. Antony's shrine in
Colombo their father knelt they stood
and then the bomb exploded all the blood
and skin the parts of the body people's
butts
I mean body in a dress inside the church
the people taking videos but they didn't
came together idea she fought with men
she took the phone and threw it away why
are you doing like this made her eyes
bleeding just come to carry my data
after that you can take videos we are
the one who carried Adeline our two
hands his blood was bleeding in her
hands their father George Norlin toid
his injuries his daughters are speaking
while his body is laid out for
visitation in the room below he'll be
buried later today
he's a bodyguard bodyguard best to him
in my body I have classes will be
finished at 2 o'clock but he will be
there at 1 o'clock she tells her sister
not to cry enough Leigh please
I don't want to say anything but there's
no God no one didn't help us no one
didn't help us I was like we can't
describe the situation we were we were
spending day we were crying we were
begging people beginning to carry our
data but they didn't come we came for
the Eastham Tom Cheshire Sky News in
Colombo